Heights where these are some Japanese
recipes for winter season
asaji its assortment of special foods we
eat to celebrate New Year's
usually people make them at the end of
December and it's eaten during January
first feel sorry
it also has a celebratory propers so
each dish has a meaning or wish for the
ER associated with them
for example shrimp it's often seen in a
city to simple rights longevity New
Year's Day is one of the biggest
holidays in Japan and many shops used to
closed during the time on top of that
people traditionally wouldn't cook
during the New Year's holiday so ah
situated to last through preservation
techniques the combination of red and
white colors represents joy and
happiness so you'll see a lot of food in
red and white color in Osage
another staple it's Mnemosyne which is
pickled daikon radish and carrot for
this video we will be using smoked
salmon instead of carrots the white
color of daikon and the red and orange
color of the smoked salmon add festivity
in the search box
ôhe contains a lot of different dishes
and it takes a lot of time to cook
traditional weights so nowadays we can
purchase of secchi from restaurants shop
or online but if you want to try to make
it I recommend this simplified recipe
tasty Japan made in the States
the most popular kind of mochi might be
mochi ice cream but when I think of
mochi my mind immediately goes to the
pounded kind you steam mochi rice and
pound until the mochi rice become a
smooth blood
freshly pounded mochi is very soft and
sticky for preservation purposes we
usually air dry mochi so it will last a
long time once it's dried it becomes
hard but will soften again when you heat
it up if you are curious how we make
machi the traditional way check out the
eating your feet mochi episode we
usually eat mochi during January often
as a New Year's food my favorite way of
eating mochi is simply rubbed with nori
seaweed and dipped in soy sauce with a
big pinch of sugar but you can enjoy
mochi in a lot of ways
Oh Tony is a soup
eaten over New Year's known for having
mochi in it each Prefecture has a
different way of making Tony
usually featuring the ingredients that
Prefecture is famous for my hometown
hiroshima is famous for oysters so some
people add oyster Zinta's oniy
however I'm allergic to oysters so I
never had one with Easter's as you can
see we used the rectangular mochi for
the first soup but the shape of mochi
differed in the east and west side of
Japan why missile Dhoni is famous in
Kyoto and Kyoto it's located in west
side so they used round mochi instead of
rectangular mochi supposedly the reason
for the different shapes it's because
eastern Japan has more cities with
higher populations like Tokyo so cutting
it into rectangular shape instead of
rolling it into balls allows for faster
production auto knee is usually a savory
soup but some prefectures eat a sweet
version like this adzuki bean soup ozoni
is also another celebratory dish for New
Year's and it's a home-cooked meal so it
may be difficult to find out the
restaurants my mama makes ozoni with
grilled eel bandha she chicken daikon
radish and carrot it's slightly smoky
from grilled eel bandha she and I always
look forward to eating for new year
there are so many varieties but mochi
it's the must-have ingredient for ozoni
ozoni
is one of my favorite food to eat during
winter time
NABBA or japanese-style haha it's such a
staple dish during winter time it's easy
to make make you warm and loaded with
healthy ingredients like vegetables and
her teammates
my favorite things to put into naba are
napa cabbage mushrooms such as shiitake
or
enoki tofu chicken and scallions but
there are lots of creative ways of
making another adding Jesus topping and
this layering style is getting really
popular spicy nabe is another popular
style for this video we use the [ __ ]
on paper it's to give a nice kick it
gives a tingly and numbing sensation
kimchi is another great ingredient to
add in if you want to make spicy naba we
call it another because now that means
popped we usually use a specific clay
pot called O'Donovan when we make
nothing but if you don't have one you
can use any kind of pot with a lid once
you eat all the vegetables and meat
don't throw away the leftover soup you
can add cooked rice to make congee where
you can add you don't or ramen noodles
to finish now there is a great dish when
you host a dinner party because it
brings people together and it's easy to
prepare you can also keep adding
ingredients as people eat it's a
never-ending food
a few years ago sculpting grated daikon
in a bag got really popular in Japan
my mama it's the one who told me about
this trend and she sent me a picture of
what she made you know what's so cute I
wanted to try myself and came up with
the idea for this video
one of the most famous styles of naba is
called chanko nabe known as a dish eaten
by small wrestlers small restaurants eat
a lot of nabe for their meals because
it's well balanced and very filling so I
figured that I would combine chanko nabe
with the sculpted daikon trend and make
another dish with a small restaurant in
it once you grate the daikon make sure
to squeeze out the moisture so it's easy
to make a shape and the nabe won't get
too watery enjoy making this dish with
your favorite animal or character thank
you so much for watching those are my
favorite winter recipes I'd like to hear
what you make during winter
[Music]
you